تصاعد التوتر بين صربيا وكوسوفو ومخاوف من
اندلاع حرب تحذير من دواء ملوث في لبنان
واليمن يستخدم في علاج السرطان بعد 102 من
الابناء اوغنديون يقرر التوقف عن الانجاب
هذه الاخبار وغيرها منقولها لكم من قناه
العربيه فاهلا بكم
في اشاره الى تصاعدي توتر بين صربيا
واغلقت سلطات الاخيره اكثر معبر الحدود
الصربي
قوات الجيش والشرطه على اهبه الاستعداد
ردنا على الاحداث الاخيره في المنطقه
وتحسبا لقيام قصبه مهاجمه الصلب الذين
يقيمون شمال البلاد والذين بداوا منذ
العاشر من ديسمبر الجاري بداوا بوضع حوافز
على الطرق ومتبادلينها اطلاقا النار مع
شرطه احتجاجا على توقيفها رجل امن سابقا
من اصول صربيا
حظرت منظمه الصحه العالميه من وجود دفعه
ملوثه من دواء يستخدم في علاج السرطان
وامراض المناعه الذاتيه في كل من لبنان
واليمن المنظمه اوضحت في بيان انه تم
العثور على دفعه ملوثه من منتج
ميثوتريكسيت بعيار 50 مليجراما في البلدين
بعد ظهور اثار ضاره على اطفال مرضى يتلقون
الدواء مشيره الى ان السلطات الصحيه في
لبنان واليمن كشفت تلوث المنتج بعد اجراء
اختبارات
مايكروبيولوجيه على القوارير المختومه
المتبقيه وشددت المنظمه على ضروره الكشف
عن المنتجات الملوثه وسحبها من التداول
لمنعه الحق الاذى بالمرضى
الى روسيا هذه المره حيث افادت وكاله تاس
الحكوميه انه سيكون بامكان عناصر القوات
الروسيه المتواجده في اوكرانيا تجميد
حيواناتهم المنويه مجانا في بنوك مخصصه
الوكاله اوضحت ان وزاره الصحه حددت
امكانيات التخصيص دعم مالي من الميزانيه
الفيدراليه لتخزين الحيوانات المنويه
للجنود الروس من عام 20 22 الى 20 24
مشيره الى ان عائلاتهم ستتمكن من هذه
الحيوانات المنويه لاجراء التلقيح
الاصطناعيه مجانا في حال موافقه شركات
التامين فيما كشفت تقارير عن ازدياد الطلب
على عمليات التجنيد منذ اكتوبر الماضي
خصوصا بعد اعلان بوتن عن حمله التعبئه
لدعم قوته في اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
في حادث مروري مروعه قتل شخص واصيب العشره
نتيجه تصادم اكثر من 200 مركبه على طريق
وسط الصين بينما ابهرت صور من الموقع حالا
من الفوضى التامه صور فقدت من الجو اظهرت
مئات سيارات الركاب والحافلات الصغيره
والشاحنات التي اصطدم العديد منها ببعضها
البعض مكومه على جزء من الطريق السريع في
مقاطعه خنا فيما اوضحت وسائل اعلام
الرسميه ان الحادث وقع نتيجه انعدام
الرؤيه تقريبا جرات تشكل الضباب وبشكل
كثيف ومفاجاه
وفي خبرنا الاخير قرر المزارع الاوغندي
موسى الذي انجب 102 من الابناء ولديه
حاليا
568 حفيدا من اثني عشر زوجه تزوجت هنا
خلال حياته قرر التوقف عن انجاب الاطفال
حتى يتمكن من الانفاق عليهم موسى البالغ
من العمر 67 عاما قال للصحفيين ان دخله
كلا خلال السنوات السابقه بسبب ارتفاع
تكاليف المعيشه خصوصا وان اسرته كبيره
مشيرا الى ان زوجته الاربعه الحاليات عشنا
في المنزل نفسه مع نحو الثلث ابناءه الذين
تتراوح اعمارهم بين سته اعوام وواحد 51
عاما
[موسيقى]